donald trump es el presidente con el
discurso más hostil hacia los hispanos
de las últimas décadas tal vez de toda
la historia de los eeuu sus comentarios
en contra de la inmigración los
mexicanos
los salvadoreños sin ir más lejos en
declaraciones como éstas explican porque
una buena parte de los hispanos no
tragan al presidente trump de bring
drugs
del extranjero
igual que ha destruido
pero amigos no penséis que en visual
político pensamos que una persona no
puede cambiar de opinión o de discurso
vamos estoy seguro que vosotros hace
diez años no pensaba es lo mismo que
pensáis hoy al menos en mi caso no es
así al fin y al cabo como dice el dicho
rectificar es de sabios y sabéis en
cierto modo aunque os pueda sorprender
trump lo está haciendo un momento que no
os lo creéis pues vaya que sí lo ha
hecho fijaos fijaos cómo han cambiado
las cosas
a la vez tenemos
y la va a estar
vaya a cambio nos parece amigos la
pregunta es qué demonios ha pasado pues
no es que trampa haya hecho una profunda
reflexión espiritual ni tampoco se debe
a que de repente se haya conmovido con
la situación de la comunidad hispana y
no tampoco ni siquiera es porque se le
haya pegado el último hit de jennifer
lópez que va para nada queréis saber qué
se esconde detrás de este cambio de
juego pues atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el voto hispano amigos que todos con
estas tres palabras porque pueden ser
clave en las próximas elecciones de 2020
en los eeuu
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea los hispanos
suponen ya el 18 por ciento de la
población total de eeuu y este
porcentaje no para de crecer
los hispanos no son solo ya la primera
minoría del país sino que además son la
minoría que más crece según todas las
proyecciones y todos los modelos
demográficos para el año 2060 el
porcentaje de población hispana superará
el 26 por ciento de la población de los
eeuu
dicho de otra forma algo más de 1 de
cada 4 estadounidenses eran hispanos y
evidentemente eso es algo que poco a
poco les va a ir dando una influencia
electoral cada vez mayor de esta forma
hacer políticas obtener discursos en
contra de los hispanos no parece la
mejor forma de cosechar éxitos políticos
obvió no os parece sin embargo embargo
esperad un momento porque hoy por hoy su
peso electoral el peso electoral de la
comunidad hispana es mucho muchísimo más
bajo de lo que podría ser
[Música]
porque es porque si hay algo que
caracteriza en eeuu al voto hispano es
que resulta muy pero que muy complicado
de movilizar
[Música]
los hispanos se caracterizan por su baja
participación electoral en las
elecciones de los eeuu mal muy mal fatal
pero porque se produce este fenómeno
como es exactamente el electorado
hispano que les preocupa cómo se reparte
el voto hispano a lo largo y ancho del
país parecen muchas preguntas pero os
prometo que vamos a responder a todas y
cada una de ellas queréis conocer cuál
es la radiografía del voto hispano en
los eeuu pues atentos
[Música]
hispanos la minoría mayoritaria si
echamos un vistazo a los principales
grupos étnicos de eeuu nos vamos a dar
cuenta de que la población hispana tiene
algunas características peculiares y
como ya hemos dicho no hablamos de una
comunidad precisamente pequeña casi 60
millones de hispanos vivían en este país
al terminar el año 2018 esto hace que
eeuu sea ya el segundo país hispano en
términos de población
[Música]
aunque parezca difícil de creer eeuu
tiene más población hispana que países
como colombia argentina o españa la
comunidad hispana los eeuu crece en
términos demográficos a un ritmo del 2%
anual y durante las últimas décadas sus
niveles de vida han mejorado mucho hoy
el desempleo hispano se encuentra
próximo a su mínimo histórico por debajo
del 5% la tasa de abandono escolar ha
bajado del 29,4 por ciento en 1992 al 92
por ciento en 2015 y la tasa de hispanos
inscritos en la universidad ha subido
del 25 al 47 por ciento en tan sólo 10
años entre el 2005 y el 2015 bien los
datos son buenos francamente buenos y
eso es algo que les augura mucha mayor
influencia económica política y social
para que os hagáis una idea tan solo
desde el año 2000 el poder de compra de
los hispanos en eeuu ha aumentado un 181
por ciento y ya se eleva a 14 billones
de dólares y sabéis qué significa esto
en los eeuu son la mayor potencia
económica hispana del mundo la economía
hispana en eeuu es más grande que toda
la economía española o la economía
mexicana el poder hispano cada vez
estará más en eeuu sin embargo no es
todo color de rosas
en términos de renta y pobreza la
población hispana aún está muy por
detrás de la población blanca y de
minorías como la asiática a pesar de la
buena evolución más del 19 por ciento de
los hispanos que así uno de cada 5 se
encuentran aún por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza según claro los estándares de
eeuu y sus ingresos medios per cápita no
llegan a los 19 mil dólares anuales la
mitad que el de los blancos pero no nos
desviemos regresemos a la política que
al fin y al cabo es de lo que va este
vídeo la población hispana es una
población muy joven su media de edad es
10 años inferior a la media nacional y
15 años más pequeña que la de la
población blanca esto es algo que
evidentemente condicionan las
preferencias y el grado de participación
política de esta comunidad
y en parte es también lo que explica que
mientras los hispanos suponen ya el 18
por ciento de la población del país en
términos de votantes potenciales apenas
suponen el 11 por ciento y encima votan
menos por todo esto es por lo que
todavía su influencia política es
relativamente pequeña pero esto esto es
algo que está cambiando
la disfunción del voto hispano
queridos amigos a simple vista si
echamos un vistazo al mapa la
distribución de la población hispana
podría indicar que son una comunidad
determinante para las elecciones porque
como todos sabéis en las elecciones
norteamericanas el candidato
presidencial que obtiene la mayoría en
un estado se hace con todos los
delegados de ese estado es así en
prácticamente todos los casos es un todo
o nada 0 o 1 por eso la victoria
presidencial depende de sumar más
delegados que el contrincante no más
votos y eso hace que los estados que más
delegados reparten sean el caramelito
que se rifan los candidatos
presidenciales
pues amigos en ese caramelito resulta
que los hispanos tienen una presencia
muy alta la población hispana se
concentra en términos absolutos
principalmente en california texas nueva
york florida e illinois 5 de los 6
estados que más delegados reparten en
las elecciones 171 de 538 totales
entendéis porque a simple vista deberían
ser cruciales en las elecciones
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que lo son y no lo son
veréis muchos analistas aseguran que el
voto hispano puede decidir presidentes
pero la verdad es que nosotros hoy por
hoy no lo tenemos tan claro al menos no
en las elecciones de 2020 el problema ya
os lo hemos dicho los hispanos apenas
van a votar
[Música]
de entre todos los grupos étnicos los
hispanos son el menos movilizado
electoralmente por ejemplo en las
últimas elecciones presidenciales en
2016 tan solo se registraron para votar
poco más del 57 por ciento con derecho a
voto eso es poco pero es todavía peor si
os decimos que al final terminaron
votando tan solo el 47 6% casi 20 puntos
menos que la participación política de
los blancos no hispanos
pero por qué diantres los hispanos pasan
tanto de las elecciones pues bien
factores hay muchos pero el más
importante es que como os hemos dicho es
una población mayoritariamente joven y
que queréis que os diga fuera de la
comunidad de visual polític parece que
los jóvenes suelen pasar más de la
política
[Música]
pero ese no es el único motivo el menor
nivel medio de estudios y de ingresos
también son cosas que alimentan la
apatía política pero claro llegados a
este punto seguro que algunos de
vosotros estáis ya pensando va ya que sí
como siempre pues amigos sí y no os lo
estamos venga a decir poco a poco esta
divergencia respecto a la población
blanca no hispana se está recortando
los hispanos cada vez estudian más cada
vez ganan más dinero y cada vez votan
más fijáos por ejemplo en lo que ocurrió
en las elecciones más recientes en las
de mitad de mandato la participación de
los latinos aumentó un 178 por ciento en
las elecciones de mitad de mandato de
2018 según los demócratas y claro
pensaréis entonces si el problema de la
movilización de la comunidad hispana se
está solucionando podrían ser estos
decisivos en 2020 bien veámoslo
[Música]
podrían los hispanos decidir la elección
del 2020
tenéis buena memoria recordáis las
palabras de trump que vimos al principio
del vídeo no no me refiero a esas en las
que insulta a los hispanos sino a las de
después a esas en las que de repente
incluso parece que les ama pues bien ese
cambio de opinión podría tener bastante
que ver con lo que os vamos a contar a
continuación los hispanos podrían marcar
la diferencia en 2020 si van a votar un
dato importante las elecciones de 2020
serán las primeras elecciones de la
historia de eeuu en las que los hispanos
serán la minoría con más peso electoral
superando ya a la población
afroamericana con 32 millones de
votantes potenciales en 2020 los
hispanos supondrán el 13% del padrón
electoral serán 2 millones más que los
votantes negros y hoy por hoy entre los
hispanos la dinámica es clara 2 de cada
3 suelen votar a candidatos del partido
demócrata pero la explicación a esto no
es que sean demócratas o republicanos
sino el empeño sistemático que ha tenido
el partido republicano por ponerles en
contra durante los últimos años
si así es frente a lo que se suele
pensar el voto hispano es extremadamente
volátil quizás el que más la mayoría no
se identifica como votante seguro de un
partido sino que oscilan mucho en
función de los candidatos las propuestas
políticas que se pongan sobre la mesa y
eso en la campaña de trump lo saben
todos los estudios apuntan a que la
economía junto a la mejora de la
educación y la seguridad son los tres
temas que más le importan a los votantes
hispanos y lo cierto es que la economía
de eeuu ha funcionado bastante bien
durante los últimos años por ejemplo los
ingresos de los hogares hispanos son los
que más rápido están creciendo o
recordad también que el desempleo
hispano se encuentra en mínimos
históricos de hecho aunque sigue siendo
escasa de apenas en 30% la popularidad
de donald está la mente de los hispanos
está repuntando ligeramente
por eso aunque os pueda resultar
sorprendente en la campaña de trump no
se han resignado ni por un segundo a no
mejorar sus niveles de apoyo entre la
comunidad hispana la campaña vamos tu
victoria es una buena prueba de ello más
hispanos piensan que la campaña de
donald trump toma en serio la comunidad
aunque son minoría quienes dicen que
votarán por él y la pregunta es podría
ser este el último cartucho de donald
trump
[Música]
un voto hispano desmovilizado de entrada
le beneficiaría pero y si se moviliza no
sería acaso más sensato reforzar su
posición en ese caladero nuevo de votos
o al menos no darles motivos para
movilizarse contra él y amigos lo cierto
es que todo apunta a que en esta ocasión
los hispanos votarán con mucha más
fuerza parece que su participación
batirá todos los récords en unas
presidenciales tal y como sucedió en las
elecciones de mitad de mandato las 1000
trans pasadas según el análisis de
univision la participación hispana se
incrementó significativamente en las
elecciones de medio mandato de 2018
respecto a las de 2014 en california
florida nevada nueva jersey nueva york y
texas suenan de algo algunos de estos
estados
exacto ahí le has dado de esos cinco
donde más se incrementó el voto hispano
ni más ni menos que 4 california florida
nueva york y texas son de los que más
delegados reparten
de otra forma son los más importantes en
las elecciones presidenciales así que he
visto lo visto lograr a la comunidad
hispana ser decisiva en esta ocasión
lograr a trump mejorar su popularidad
entre los hispanos desde luego a pesar
de todo si la economía va bien no es
descabellado que ocurra sin embargo la
guerra comercial está teniendo
consecuencias duras para eeuu y la
desaceleración económica es un hecho si
2020 se pone peor puede incluso que sean
los hispanos los que terminan echando a
donald trump de la casa blanca lo que
tendría gracia en fin ahora turno para
ti conseguir a trump ser reelegido
haciendo que los hispanos olviden todo
lo que ha dicho y hecho
por contra estaremos a las puertas de
una gran venganza
dejadnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios y si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y por cierto un último
mensaje si veis visual política eres
hispano y vives en los eeuu si puedes
tienes que ir a votar vota lo que te dé
la gana pero vota en fin muchas gracias
y una vez más nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo
[Música]